we have the story from Bloomberg U.S
prosecutors opened probe of FTX months
before its collapse
Sweeping in pre-examined crypto
exchanges with offshore reach Manhattan
prosecutors recently changed Tac as FTX
unraveled so they knew about this
yeah how can they not this company came
out of nowhere and had all the huge
institutional money everyone was asking
the question where did they get all this
money and the corporate media in
response to this said he's the new JP
Morgan and Chase he's a genius and and
no one had the receipts no one knew what
was going on here and SBF was also given
hundreds of thousands of dollars to the
house committee members that are
investigating him I don't I don't see
this this going anywhere except for a
potential false flag being used here in
order to bring in more regulations bring
in more control of what essentially
would be a decentralized cryptocurrency
but now is going to be hyper focused to
be a central bank digital currency that
of course is going to be a part of the
Great reset and build back better agenda
which they've been calling for for a
very long time and this is the way this
is the false flag that they're going to
get it I don't know though I feel like
this stuff is shaking confidence in
crypto absolutely well if they want
people to adopt a reserve crypto this is
not the way a federal reserve
cryptocurrency a digital dollar is
essentially what they want they don't
everyone just on bitcoin they don't want
everyone on they don't want everyone on
decentralized platforms they want
everyone on their platforms so they
could say hey cryptocurrency was bad
because it was Reckless and they had
scams we have a bigger scam here the US
dollar for you that's going to be
getting the good principles from it and
we're not going to be doing the bad
principles even though we're we really
have all the best make every transaction
you ever have publicly available exactly
yeah people would not track that Trace
everything automatically take money out
of accounts like a social credit score
system like they have in China so this
is essentially the end game here and
Central Bank digital currencies are
something that's being rolled out with
the New York Federal Reserve just a
couple days ago and we're seeing this
with the G20 just announcing that
they're going to have an international
Health passport that they're going to
implement all over the world so when we
look at you know the scams in our
society there's a lot of them FTX is
just scratching the surface to all the
bigger scams out there and just
including perhaps tether and just as as
an addendum uh Alameda the
um hedge fund uh set up by Sam bankman
freed that's associated with the FDX
Scandal they were the major backer of
tether in fact they're one of the two
major uh purchasers of tether on their
exchange and so they're interesting
connections there as well looks like FTX
was kind of money laundering scheme to
filter through the sort of democrat
machine and the Clinton Overworld and
tether may be a kind of BCCI which is
used for sort of
um CIA Iran the new Iran Contra type
operations uh globally yeah that was an
interesting Saga the the BCCI Scandal
right
um can you expand on that just a little
bit because I think that that's an
important history lesson that we should
kind of revisit right especially when it
comes to understanding the largest part
of the the larger intelligence agencies
and their involvement with the big Banks
and how they actually work together to
screw you over right the reason these
things are important is that the the
government does not reinvent its own
Playbook very often at all and if
there's an historical antecedent that
serves an important function you can
pretty much bet that it still exists in
some modified version and so the fact
that the BCCI existed in the 70s and 80s
which is a bank set up by Pakistani
allegedly but it was probably set up by
an intelligence agency and it you know
major scam it screwed over its uh many
of its depositors it had a lot of shady
figures drug cartels arms dealers all
kinds of shady folks working through it
operating through it and then the
question was why was this manifest
obvious scam allowed to function for so
long uninterrupted well it's because the
CIA was in on it and the primary
beneficiary of it and so that gets to
the sort of crypto thing is like some
scams are allowed to exist because
they're of the scam of the most
valuable player so to speak and in a
kind of Darkly ironic twist that may in
fact end up being the Saving Grace of
tether and crypto more broadly is that
there are too many major scams wrapped
up into it that it's essentially too big
to fail at least on a medium timeline
yeah me and Tim were talking about this
earlier today if there was a way to
destroy cryptocurrencies in Bitcoin and
decentralized currencies what would they
be doing differently than what they're
doing right now and and I think it also
provided a huge potential and it still
might in many aspects of allowing people
to have a lot of freedom Barack Obama
called Bitcoin the ability of human
beings to have Swiss bank accounts
inside of their own Pockets I think that
that's a power that threatens a lot of
people and I think what we're seeing
with FTX what we're seeing with SBF is a
deliberate destruction of that power
right but do you you don't really have
that power if you're operating through
an exchange on an exchange absolutely
right yeah
also honeypots as well exactly so like
they're two different things there's the
I guess and I don't mean this derisively
there's a the nerd money kind of
function of Bitcoin which is like you
have your own Keys you do all these but
it's a pain in the ass and people don't
really want to do it it's not Grandma
friendly exactly but the scalable
version of Bitcoin
um is replete with all of these scams
and again maybe it's it's not going to
fall down precisely because the scams
are too valuable in the in the in the
specific case of tether potentially
being the new BCCI it's literally the
official cryptocurrency of the rohingo
Rebel group in Myanmar which is bizarre
that a rebel group would have an
official cryptocurrency but that's the
case
um it's beloved by the Syrian uh the the
Sunni moderates in Syria that John
McCain loves so much it's beloved by
cartels which of course the US
intelligence agencies don't have any
relationship with yeah it's not like
they help them get their start in Mexico
with that secret police unit that they
were training down there they had
nothing to do with that right well come
on you guys everything's a little over
the time
it's like Obama was giving weapons
exactly it's not like we had the Iran
Contra Scandal that was laundering
weapons and heroin and and cocaine into
the country and guns and weapons it's
funny because you say that Meme where
it's like okay so look I know the CIA
was doing bad stuff in the 50s the 60s
the 70s the 80s the 90s the 2000s the
2010s but nothing's changed they've
never been out and never been held
accountable right so like so they're
definitely they definitely changed
they're definitely not doing that now
yep that's a that's a new management yes
yeah and for and and you know the way
this country is going there's that
there's that uh viral video of the dude
in Arizona with the dreads and he's like
yelling about about box number three in
Arizona stuff oh that's a great video
and I'm just like I'm watching that
video and I'm thinking the average
person in this country does not like
what the intelligence agencies are doing
so who are they serving but themselves
now maybe these people have the idea
like well they don't know what's good
for them okay well dude like that defies
the core of what this country is
supposed to be it's supposed to be
dangerous Freedom not peaceful slavery
just you as an intelligence officer
whatever deciding you know what's best
for us you don't and clearly all of this
luxury has been bad for us it's created
a whole generation of gluttonous morons
so maybe maybe we need things to be a
little bit less luxurious and people
need to go out and chop some Lumber to
heat their homes maybe all of this
luxury is making weak people which makes
everything worse for everybody and all
we get is a bunch of whiny complainers
and um one of the young Elon call them
the whole monitors home monitors I said
a national Hall monitors yeah there's
only so much of an economy that you can
make being a homeowner but that's that's
really it those guys who are working
that oil rig we watching that video a
moment ago those guys are doing hard
work the lady at Twitter Hall Monitor
Vice media Paul monitors BuzzFeed Hall
monitors NBC News Hall monitors all they
do they walk around complaining
contributing nothing yeah we got to do
something about that they're bogging us
down I want to post jokes
I know I want to post memes yeah without
being yeah afraid of getting censored or
or Express political ideas or or debate
political ideas that might be a little
edgy or controversial I want to have the
ability to talk through bad ideas you
know and we we still let's be honest
here we're still testing the waters with
Twitter we still don't have that fully
and that's that's a shame because that's
what we had before and then we were LED
astray by the centralization of it all
and now the solution is going to be more
centralization which is absolutely
absurd you mean with Elon or what more
centralization as far as what's
happening with cryptocurrencies with
what's happening with uh social media
platforms being in the hands of less and
less people and uh you know media
Outlets being in control of less and
less people as well everything's being
centralized so weird like centralization
minus censorship really was sort of The
Sweet Spot because Central
centralization allowed speech at scale
so that brief period in the internet
when there were centralized platforms
major platforms
but before the speech Crackdown post
2016 was really kind of The Sweet Spot
and maybe it just can't sustain it maybe
the regime is simply incompatible with
that level of free speech at scale maybe
no regime is compatible but certainly
ours isn't given how
um how ridiculous and ultimately
untenable it is
um and so when they say that you know
Elon Musk is a national security threat
free speech is a national security
threat I think that's true in in quite a
literal sense is that if people are
allowed to speak freely on the whole
host of things that I'm you know not
even able to mention now
um that is I don't think the regime can
really survive it and so it's an
existential issue from their point of
view and that kind of illustrates the
stakes uh associated with what Elon Musk
is doing you know what you know what
really grinds my gears I hear this all
the time people will tweet something
like tell me one time in history when
the people censoring speech were the
good guys because it's just like World
War II the United States yeah were we
the bad guys I don't know like the US
had an office of censorship but it's
it's like people just assume outright
that there's that there's there's never
a reason for controlling information of
course there is like in war and things
like that to your point the intelligence
agencies probably do think that you know
we're in a constitative conflict and we
need to be able to control information
if we're going to win but that can that
conflicts what this country is supposed
to be people having a right to choose if
they can't be informed they can't choose
so this country is clearly already lost
if that's the case but I will point out
in World War II with the office office
of censorship
loose lips sink ships and uh this was it
there were sensors who would stop things
from appearing in newspapers in the
radio censorship all over the United
States of the federal office of
censorship because we're at War well you
know there's there's a logical approach
to this specifically when it comes to
saying hey there's all these troops
moving in this direction going here
obviously you can't allow that kind of
information during Warfare because it's
going to give the enemy the upper hand
but but treason doesn't fall under Free
Speech no but it's but it's not that
it's that someone might be alike I work
at a steel mill and they just some crazy
thing happened where the alarm went off
today that's the kind of thing they
don't they loose lip sync ships wasn't
just about telling people where our
military was some people didn't know
that it was about giving up information
on on what you were doing to people who
shouldn't know about it they wanted
everyone to shut up it's a fine line too
because we're we're you know where do
you draw the boundaries because you know
in the you know in the United States we
did have the Japanese internment camps
we did have the bombing of Dresden we do
have a lot of policies that we could
definitely criticize the United States
for which we should have criticized
which criticism could have prevented but
that didn't happen because of that
censorship effort as well so again where
do where's that fine line I think that's
impossible I don't know Dan do you have
an answer
well I think
um I think censorship and information
control are necessary to any type of
regime I think the important issue is if
the noble lie is necessary in in some
degree as you know the famous thing from
the Republic
uh the problem is that we become a the
ignoble lie and it's less that oh we
want a total you know free for all free
speech is that fundamentally what
America has come to represent what I
call the globalist American Empire is
really
um you know the wokeness or whatever you
want to call it really is basically the
um de facto official religion the de
facto official ideology of the United
States and once it's seeped that deeply
into the marrow of the body politic then
anything that's set up to sustain the
security of It ultimately just
reinforces that ideology that's the
problem that we're in
um and that's not
per se a problem of censorship as such
it's a problem of what the regime has
become in its most fundamental sense
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time